Okay, I'll if you could please introduce yourself, your name and today's date in our location.
I'm Albert C. PAR, where we're at our home in Gresham, Oregon.
On these two to Avenue, and the date I'd be was the 18th, 18th of June 2014.
Terrific. Well, we'll start at the beginning. You were born in, is it Tulea?
Tulea?
Yeah.
So what was your family doing there?
My dad was working in the copper mines and a big army depot.
The Tulea was ordered in St. Paul during World War II.
And after the war ended, he decided he wanted to leave Utah and move up to Oregon,
where his brother was, his family was in Rosberg.
So we moved to Rosberg. I think in 1946, something like that,
for 46 or early 47.
And that's why I want to, all my schooling and group there in Rosberg.
Did you have siblings?
Yes, I have one brother, and we're no longer brother, and a sister
that's four years younger. And they both live in the state.
A sister lived in Canby, my brother lived in that lake,
grew over Lake Oswego.
So your dad was in the copper mines originally, but I didn't understand
he was in the forest products industry.
Yeah, he worked in the saw mills and plywood mills in the Rosberg area.
And eventually ran a film station for a while,
and some other things just sort of retired as a handyman,
and we can't, it's place in Rosberg.
Growing up in Rosberg, did you have any,
did you have memories of the timber culture at that time?
Yeah, there was a lot of, you know, that's what
made the world hummed down there.
And in those days, there were still hearing a lot of those,
you know, first of all the trees,
and it would be Douglas Firso, and you'd take up a whole logging truck
that diameter would be.
And you'd see those coming down the road,
and the roads are certainly very primitive up in the mountains,
a lot of them, or we'd scrap them out, pay it,
it was very primitive, but that was almost exclusive to me.
There's also a big farming industry in Rosberg,
in the Garden Valley, a vegetable farming,
can't load beans, that sort of thing.
I remember a lot of those kids,
and during high school, high school worked in the farms,
and the valleys are in the Rosberg area.
Like that's why I started working in the farming areas,
to say about money and good work in the state.
So what kinds of jobs did you do?
Well, I started in junior high school picking beans,
the pole beans, and then eventually,
that was by a propound sort of job,
and then eventually I got a job by the hour,
a sort of an overseer of that,
and also the, you know, in the early summers,
and run in camel fields.
And then the guy worked for a headrock 25 acres of camel open,
to meet those instructors, that sort of thing,
and I would work all from me,
to bring on through the late summer,
we fall after school on weekends for the farmers.
Was there much market labor in the area at that time?
Not much at all, very, very little.
In fact, that's why the school base,
to run the school buses downtown,
and all kids out to work in the fields,
and I don't think that's done anymore.
I think the children don't want to work out in the hot sun,
but that's what it used to be done,
back in the 50s and 60s,
before that.
It was getting to get yourself into the school
and run school buses,
but a little bit of the various bean fields,
and then you work all day to bring you back to the school,
and you could get yourself home somehow.
When do you remember about,
to your dad's work in the sun,
I mean, what was that typical work experience like for him, you know?
It was very hard work,
and, you know,
of course the mills were not air conditioned
or heated during any of that nature.
And so it was hard, it was hard,
and not the safest thing in those days either.
But it was very labor intensive.
You know, all the wallwork was done by hand,
and, you know, of course, power solves that sort of thing.
But you're walking to a modern plywood mill,
you know, there's very few people,
and it's all automated.
But in those days, everything was,
it was done by hand,
including making the plywood sheet, you know,
later by a layer.
Like I had a job on summer after in college,
working in plywood mill,
it was my job to make the plywood.
It started out with, you know,
the big flat piece,
the four-way piece that put the,
a machine just spit out glued to cross pieces
to even slap those down somewhere
and then flop another sheet saw.
And in the building, you physically built the piece
of plywood with your hands,
and then stacked them up and put them in
a big hop, pressed and pressed them,
and started another batch.
But it was all hand labor you see.
Including, you know,
they do it with the glue pieces,
and all parts of the process were had.
So they put a lot of people,
compared to what now they do.
Sounds a little repetitious.
Yeah, it's boring,
but it was good money, you know,
for a kid in those days.
How much you might have of us here back down?
She was a school teacher,
and so since we moved to Jerusalem,
she got a job in a,
and looking glass or a teaching there in looking glass,
and would go out there every day during the school year.
And so we were very young,
so we were,
we would often have baby citizen, that sort of thing.
And then eventually she moved to the Rosbury School System
and retired for 30 years or whatever.
How was Rosbury going up for you?
I loved it.
It was a, it was a, you know,
a safe place to be,
and a lot of friends there still do,
so have my rotary contacts.
And we, I liked it the weather was nice,
and it's a lovely place to live.
And it was of course a small town,
but I have to be a very fond memories of it.
A really great place.
Schools were good,
and it's, everything to,
everything to recommend it in my mind.
What were your hobbies as a biology do for fun?
I was pretty busy working.
We lived on a small farm,
so we had a lot animals that always had pigs and chickens,
and now occasionally a cow on a steer,
and that sort of thing.
So it was busy with that sort of thing,
and then hobbies as a guy over was cars.
Got real interested in hot rod racing,
and much of it was being runny,
hot rod, you'd see back in the 50s,
and drag race on the roads,
and that sort of thing.
It had a good time, but it was entertaining.
It was a nice place to grow up.
How about your experience at school?
The Rosbury had good schools in those days,
and I presumably still do,
and so I learned what I was,
for a few years,
a few years in my school,
I didn't take school very seriously,
and I got by,
but then nothing to brag about academic excellence.
But time I got to high school,
and later on,
and I started taking school,
and were seriously worked on getting to grades,
and that sort of thing.
But again, they were very tolerant,
and as active in student government in high school,
and so on.
So I had a good time.
I enjoyed looking back with high school with great fondness.
I saw a lot of friends from the Rosbury graduating class,
and I see them in fact.
I was just talking to one on the phone this morning,
and everybody from Rosbury.
Your friendship lasted,
it started in life,
to the last of the lifetime,
different from your high school experience.
They seem education was an emphasis in your family,
I heard from the time I was very small.
You want to work hard so you can go to college,
and my dad would always say,
so you don't have to work in the mills like I have to work.
And once you work in the mills,
you could see what he meant.
And so it was a good influence
working in the mills,
and hard labor on the farms.
There might be a better career,
or perhaps more,
in terms of ease,
but also security,
because the mills are always having strikes
before the union really got strong,
and then people get laid off,
and it was not the most secure environment.
So a lot of anxiety,
but from my father and the other parents as well,
because of the changing nature of the scene,
in terms of the mills,
and who is all who owned this when they buy some mills,
and everybody get fired,
and so on,
and it was,
I couldn't understand why my father was always apprehensive.
It was an uncertain time.
How did you develop your interest in science?
I was always fairly good at it.
I wrote a math,
and then science things always came easy to me.
It just, I think,
one of my buddies,
and I did well at it,
and I just got,
I was always interested in how things work.
I built radios from time,
I was like a teenager,
and you got interested in radios that led in the interest,
you know,
and physics and electronics.
I always had that interest in high school.
Then when I went on to college,
I was the first thing I thought about as having a major,
in terms of physics and math.
So it just,
I think,
things sort of select you by your abilities.
Some people have great musical skills,
and other kinds of skills,
language skills,
and there's some of us who have math and science skills,
and just attributes and interests too,
and from bliever,
and there's dispositions and characteristics of people
that allow them to succeed.
Because some people,
no matter how hard they were,
have a very difficult time on mathematics.
I would see that when I was teaching,
and there wasn't that they were,
you know,
necessarily stupid people or any of that in nature,
just that they didn't have those particular abilities
and traps and interests with abilities.
So people tend to end up,
I think, and things,
if they're going to be successful,
if they have good abilities.
I thought that's what worked out for me.
Was there anybody who during your high school time
was a mentor for you,
or somebody who got interested in these things
or didn't sort of memorize from what then?
I had a series of very good science teachers,
or high school physics teachers,
and chemistry teachers,
and math teachers I might add,
that always encouraged,
and encouraged the students,
and kept you on the straightener and turned to the warning,
and did a good job.
So I think the,
I had the benefit of a bunch of good teachers,
so most of the more veterans from World War II,
the ones I can remember,
had gotten to school on the GI Bill,
and went into education.
They were really excellent teachers,
a lot of them.
So benefit to our students.
We went to Oregon State College,
beginning in 1960.
How did you decide to go to OSC?
I had a scholarship from the,
from the Navy,
and it was in our OTC scholarships,
and that was the place
that had that program.
I'm also I wanted to major in a science program,
sort of state was a natural choice,
and they had the,
in our OTC scholarship as well.
So it's a,
a confluence of events,
and interest as well as,
that's what the scholarship aid was.
Were you in our OTC in high school?
No, no, no, not at all.
But they was one of those exams you take,
and you selected,
and so on,
and that was a competitive fact.
So that was part of your experience,
then in college was being in,
in that era too.
In our OTC.
Yes, yes.
As I was in that for two and a half years,
then I decided that it would be better for me
to continue in science,
and to continue as a naval officer.
And just a rule from that program,
just to set my time in science program.
What did that program entail for you?
The Navy program.
It would entail the summer cruises.
After your freshman year,
you went on,
you know, camped,
and then some other places.
After the sophomore year,
we went to Texas for a while,
and Air Force based on the Corpus Christi,
and then another month or so at San Diego.
And so it's a good experience.
I really think well those experiences in the Navy,
in the summer programs.
And then if I had stayed in the program
the third year,
after your junior year,
you'd be going to onboard a ship.
And some sort of capacity.
But I never, never went that far.
I put some part of my junior year.
Was there training during this school year to you?
Yes.
To the regular RCZ program.
I think it was, you had to regular class three times a week.
Then one day,
there was a drill,
where you had to breathe out.
It was a marching-out side down there.
All those fields are,
other buildings,
there's down there,
the quance of that building really.
There's still the same building,
I don't know if I could've done that by the Colosseum,
and then so forth.
It was the same building then,
and those were all world war two quance of us.
It's amazing.
It's still standing.
With all those fields are all vacant.
There's not a lot of the development.
That would be out there marching,
mostly it's same.
Yeah.
There used to be quite a few of those quance of that,
so I can't put some trees off.
Yeah.
But what do you remember about,
to sort of your first impressions
of college and, of course, Alice?
I liked it.
I was,
when I got there,
I was selected to go into some sort of,
they were trying some living arrangement programs.
And they were also getting started
with the Colosseum Honors Program at that time.
And I was enrolled in that,
and they put people in that Honors Program,
which was your freshman,
the whole four on the,
the first four of Coffern Hall,
I believe,
he was Coffern Hall,
the first four were the people
that were chosen for this Honors Program,
and they encouraged extra cultural activities
and they had advisors in and so forth.
And I was,
pretty much a,
pretty nice bunch of,
of Alice who would,
you know,
well fairly successful in high school.
There were,
then,
select the first,
this Honors Program arrangement.
I don't know if they still do that,
and I have my idea,
but it was a,
I was a,
introductory program,
so the people that we were,
my roommates and then the people,
and the whole were,
pre-selected out by,
by someone in the university,
as part of this Honors Program,
a test to have the better students
and one location.
The people they perceived would be better,
so they ultimately turned out or not,
I don't know,
but that was the idea at the time.
And there was extra curriculum activities as well.
Yeah, and then the Honors Program,
you took an addition to your regular courses,
there was at least one seminar a week,
a small,
small bunch of people,
sometimes one on one,
with one of the professors at working on projects.
I found that very beneficial.
I worked with,
a,
a biology,
a botany,
and a botany professor wants,
and physics professors,
and into biology.
So it was,
it was,
it was an interesting time,
and did that every year for your whole four years.
And then you would,
when you graduated,
to get a Honors Designation on your,
on your diploma.
Interesting,
see you're helping assist with their researches.
Yeah, you would do,
and then do a little projects on your own,
yeah.
And it was,
it was,
it was always sort of interesting.
And then just talk about,
you know,
their field of research,
and they try to learn a little bit a little bit about it.
What was that?
It was a broadening experience.
Yeah.
But you got to work sort of one-on-one with,
with the faculty members.
Or in some cases,
as my physics program is working with a senior graduate student,
but come in once in twice a week,
and we were working on projects that,
the physics program.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm interested to be here.
Talk about this though.
There was,
I've done that on this program.
Apparently it started right around the new started.
It was cut,
as a result,
about major five in the early 90s.
And then was replaced by the University of Honors College,
which came about five years later.
It sounds like it's a little different.
Yeah.
But your experience was.
There was,
you,
in some of the classes were segregated
in terms of the people in the Honors program.
But by and large,
you just met with everybody else,
and did these extra things.
You know,
with the seminars,
you just go,
one or three hours,
seminar,
credit course,
and get credit for that as well.
It was a,
main experience was being able to work with,
one on one of the,
with a,
with a researcher,
some sort of,
and,
explore new areas,
so it was a very beneficial.
So when you went to college,
as you have a sense of what you wanted to do,
in terms of your studies,
because,
as I turn that out,
you took,
looked at your academic records,
about a lot of classes,
and to get two degrees and four years.
Was that your plan from the beginning?
I sort of liked it,
because I was,
the,
the math,
and the physics were,
happened to be easy for me,
and the things that caused me to trouble were,
the form language requirements,
and that was really hard for me.
I spent probably more time on French,
when I was taking it,
and then I,
then I did on the physics courses,
because it's just different abilities.
But,
no,
I just,
it took as much as I could,
and I also liked the math courses,
but I'd taken a lot of math
in high school,
and you know,
really liked it.
And I had some good professors, too,
at both departments.
It was a fun environment.
So I looked back on my days,
both at undergraduate and graduate school,
with great farmers,
because I enjoyed it,
and it was hard work,
and so forth.
It was a really nice time you were doing something,
you really wanted to do,
and able to do,
and sort of free from the,
necessities that happened to make a living otherwise,
and work in a workplace and so on.
It was a time of your life,
and a prolonged time in my case,
because I went on the graduate school.
We were doing exactly what you wanted to do.
And that's a,
that's a real good feeling.
It's very, very good for the soul.
Did you have a sense of a particular specialty
within math or physics,
at that point in your life,
or that point?
No, I didn't know,
but the,
and then in fact,
the curriculum was sort of everybody took the same thing.
There were a few electors like in physics,
you could take it.
Maybe into me,
you're all as you're something of that nature.
Or ocean sciences was getting started back
that some people would maybe take a few of that,
but by and large,
the physics curriculum was pretty well fixed.
And since I was getting a math major too,
I didn't have a lot of a slot
I had to take the,
the required courses,
and to fill the,
the social science requirements as well.
I think that PE requirements in those days too,
you had to take some of your classes out.
Yeah, I don't know if it was still current when you were in school,
and you used to have to learn how to swim
in order to graduate.
Yeah, and that was,
that was,
yeah, you had to take a swimming course
in those days,
and I,
I always thought it was awful.
There,
there's no swimming suit,
you swim moon.
And I thought that was just a trotious.
I mean,
there's no earthly sense in it.
There was just some very peculiar people
who were in the swim program,
and I was letting the department.
I think that was my,
that was always my opinion,
just strange folks.
You're not the first person to say that to me.
But were there any professors that made
a particular impact upon you?
You can think of it.
Yeah,
like the entomology professor I worked with,
John Latton,
I believe,
was the same,
was very influential.
It got me interested in,
in philosophy,
in science,
and a whole range of things,
so that we're in a very little
about it tomorrow,
but a little bit.
And we had some good professors
in the physics department,
and enjoyed that a great deal.
They were good,
because they were student focused,
and he really got a chance
to have a lot of experiences
directly with the teachers.
Yeah,
Latton also was a book lecture.
Oh,
I didn't know that,
at the time out.
Yeah,
did you work while you were in school?
Assump,
the NROTC program,
kept me pretty busy,
but also,
Liedron helped by grading papers,
and that sort of thing
for both the math department
and the physics department.
And that was a small amount of money,
but it actually helped.
But it was primarily
in being grading papers,
and acting as sort of a assistant to some professor.
And that sort of,
I didn't,
you're working a restaurant or any of that sort of thing.
Well,
when you were studying physics,
especially,
I'm just didn't know about the technologies
that were important to students at that point.
Well,
we had the technology of the 50s,
and in early 60s,
and so there were,
there were a lot of old-heal-packered
and tectonics measuring equipment,
that sort of thing,
and the optic stuff,
was all the classical optics material.
Well,
a lot of that's probably still,
still the same because things like optics
haven't been in the introduction of the laser,
and so that tectonics haven't changed that much.
So the lens is,
and that sort of thing,
you know,
probably the same knowledge,
so they were then.
So they had,
I think,
well, a quick laboratory,
isn't for the time.
And it was,
it was good.
Yeah.
I'm always interested in knowing about the area
before computers,
because computers,
we know anyway.
Yeah.
Well, there was none of that then.
And it was,
I,
I started taking computer course,
I always thought this was sort of funny,
and I showed up in this class.
And in terms of mostly other people,
already knew what they were doing.
And, you know,
so the professor was talking to them.
Somebody like me,
it was just out of lunch,
eventually I just quit the course.
You know,
they mean you tell you where the computer was,
and how you did anything.
They started talking about a bunch of stuff
that they were, you know, more advanced.
It wasn't an introductory course of all.
Which is what was alleged to be.
And so it was sort of a bad experience quite frankly.
I made a introduction to the computers
that they had to,
something that it worked and saved that time.
I have no idea what it was.
I never personally saw it.
Because I got out of the business.
And then really get started into computers
till later in graduate school,
in very late in graduate school.
And then I became a,
that I taught for a few years.
And Alabama,
we ought to start automating some of our equipment down.
But it was still back then.
Those those they liked.
And the sixies that were still teletypes,
that sort of,
kind of console.
And that was,
modems them very slow.
I mean,
people just wouldn't recognize it now.
it wouldn't have the patience for it.
Did you see,
you lived in a dorm,
initially,
did you stay in the dorms all four years?
No,
I didn't.
I,
I didn't really like the dorms,
they're sort of noisy.
And I'm the sort of person.
I really have to have a sort of quiet.
And it's a little solitude.
And the dorms are always very, very noisy.
And so the second year,
I,
and a friend,
found an apartment,
over by the SAE house.
It's the church,
it's a church that owned a beautiful
two-story house.
They rented out parts of the for students.
So my friend and I moved in and moved in there.
And at that time,
that wasn't,
that wasn't really allowed.
I mean,
you had to,
it's an undergraduate,
we're supposed to live in student approved housing.
Well, this wasn't student approved housing.
We just moved in there.
But eventually the dean caught up with us.
The dean and man,
sent us letters which we ignored,
and so forth.
But eventually came over.
And,
not from the door.
I don't remember his name,
but he was very nice man.
And we talked to him a while.
I told him I just,
you know, we liked it there.
And it was,
and I was getting good grades and being successful.
So it wasn't like we were,
and the same with my roommate.
We were,
we're flunking out of school.
Something that was actually,
can be quite successful as a living arrangement.
But so he,
bless his heart.
He went next door.
We're a graduate student in his wife.
We're living.
Who I didn't know.
And got them to sign that they would be
our plotters or whatever they call it.
Signed that they would keep in mind.
So,
we're going to be came with gentlemen housing.
And I hadn't realized that it was a process
to turn a living situation
into a university recognized.
But then that was the end of that.
Never heard any more about it.
And I stayed there for the next two years.
And the third year,
we,
by finally,
we lived a roommate and I lived in a,
and a,
a place called provost towers or something like that.
It's big old.
It was a high rise building at that time.
And then an important area.
I mean, then the provost area.
And that, that was fine too.
But that first one was a sophomore when we
ran into the dean.
That, that had a little concern.
But, you know,
I was trying to do what I thought was best for me.
And it turned out fine.
Well,
at that point,
this is still true to some degree.
But at that point,
the Greek system was very big on campus.
And I'm wondering what it was like to,
not be part of that,
to have,
to have a social life,
but not necessarily being engaged with the Greek system.
We're not even engaged with the Greek system.
We're not much.
I had some friends who were in fraternity.
In fact,
I met some of the fellows that lived across the street
at the SAE house.
And they were all fine.
We got long fine.
There's no problems.
And we,
since I had,
I was doing a double major in health networking.
I didn't have a lot of time for socializing.
And I'm not.
In those days,
I didn't,
you know,
think much of party and caring on it.
Like I emphasized.
I liked it quite,
so I couldn't get my work done.
So I,
I never really thought about that at the fraternity.
And they were,
a little more expensive,
too,
I think, to live in,
by sharing an apartment.
The room was relatively small.
Another kind of shared the rent.
And you did a lot of own cooking in this,
and food preparation.
And it was really fairly inexpensive.
I would,
I would budget about $1,000,
maybe $100 a year to go to work in state in those days.
And with a little judicious spending and care,
you could make almost that amount.
And in a summary,
the working on the farms,
or plywood mill,
or a saw mill,
or something,
that nature,
and so you could quite easily work your way through school.
Of course,
I had a scholarship to the first two and a half years
that paid the tuition.
And I hope they gave us $50 a month,
for living to as part of that Navy program.
So,
you know,
small stipend.
So,
the financial aspects are going to college,
and the,
and the 60s,
and so,
we're just not burdensome.
Almost anybody with a will
could,
could go to any school that they wanted.
The weather was,
yeah,
Oregon University of Oregon,
Oregon State,
Southern Oregon College.
Any school,
because you could work your way through fairly straightforward.
Now,
I think that's not a quite probable board likely,
not possible.
Did you have any major extracurricular activities
that you did during college?
Not much.
Except the,
I've played,
you know,
ten of some things like this with friends,
but I didn't,
during a lot of clubs,
or anything of that nature,
because, you know,
it was pretty busy,
and it focused on my,
my activities.
But in a lot of friends,
we did think we'd often,
you know,
have your,
your Friday night out at the bar,
down there at the peacock,
whatever reason one was barstand there,
and,
and have a good time,
and so on.
But that was it.
But I didn't join,
I didn't join a lot of clubs,
or anything of that nature.
Any particular hangout,
besides the peacock?
Not really.
And,
but,
for everybody,
you know,
that have a few beers on their own,
it's basically,
if you've got a way to get it,
even though it's,
not a lot of legal in my respect,
but the,
the students,
as always,
are interpricing,
and it was never a problem.
Why do I ask you about a few events
that happened at Oregon State,
when you were there at the first one?
In 1961,
Oregon State College became Oregon State University.
That makes much of an impact on you,
giving memory of that.
I have a memory of it,
and I,
and the people there thought was a big deal.
I remember everybody being a thused about it,
because I guess,
and a lot of people's minds,
the main university has more prestige
and meaning than college.
And I guess it does.
It was,
personally at that time,
I,
I didn't care that much.
I, as I recall,
because, you know,
I had known as Oregon State College OSC,
you know,
as I,
last, where I applied,
it didn't mean a lot to me,
in terms of,
of later things,
because,
you know,
whether the degree,
whether the degree said,
Oregon State College
or State University,
to me,
it didn't mean very much.
But, you know,
to some people,
I can,
I can understand it.
It didn't mean a lot to them.
Because I think,
in the,
in the academic hierarchy,
being called a university,
it's,
it's more meaningful,
and,
you know,
college,
it's more restricted term,
doesn't imply the research
and graduate programs,
and so forth,
that you,
you think of it in terms of the university.
And I think that was,
that was the goal, of course.
In October of 1962,
as the Columbus State Storm,
you remember that?
Bigly,
yeah.
And, you know,
it's a,
a bad storm.
And,
and I,
didn't affect me in any way,
you know,
directly,
we didn't lose any,
any of our homework,
any of that nature,
you know,
in progress,
like the parents' rules,
we've been having problems.
And so I didn't,
it didn't,
drastically,
drastically affect me in any way,
then pay attention to it.
Well,
I don't get it,
you're a big football fan,
but Terry Baker,
when the high central fee in 1962,
as well,
you remember the,
yeah.
Oh, yeah.
There was a lot of who planned,
and he was a great athlete,
because he was a,
he started in the basketball,
basketball as well.
And,
yeah,
I didn't know in person,
of course,
but he was famous in his own time.
And I used to go to football games,
and the,
I think the students got in,
you know,
freer,
or almost nothing.
If it was,
it was a game,
and I,
you know,
it's not otherwise engaged.
I didn't try to get down to watch,
right?
I enjoyed football.
It's the one sport I do care for.
I do ball or baseball fan that much.
But I do like football.
And so,
I go to some of the games,
but,
and all the football associated with it.
So, I enjoyed,
I enjoyed the athletic team.
Yeah.
Well,
what was your sense of course,
I'll set the time,
at somewhat smaller place than it is now,
obviously.
Any particular relationship with the town?
I,
I like core balance.
It was the,
the people,
and the,
there was no crime to speak of.
And,
you know,
I,
I dreamed my bicycle outside in,
in my house or the apartment where I lived.
I,
I never had a stall in,
and this sort of thing.
And,
I never had a stalling from,
from the building or anything like that.
So,
yeah,
I enjoyed,
I had no negative memories of it at all.
Of course,
it's a lovely campus.
I always thought,
or you can say,
it had a truly lovely campus in the spring,
whatever things in bloom,
and the landscaping is really, really nice.
And,
in those days,
they didn't have all those,
cut streets,
all the streets went through.
And,
you didn't have all the,
uh,
limited access that you have now.
And,
but parking was pretty critical.
I mean,
it was not easy.
When I,
I lived in my apartment,
there was no problem with that.
In the dorm,
we had to park way down there by,
past the tennis courts,
where the,
call it seem to walk across the fields,
and so forth.
There was no parking close by.
So,
it was inconvenient for some of that cars in those days.
But, uh,
yeah,
it was, I like,
probably also,
it's a lovely little town.
And, uh,
it's a sort of,
a nicer place to live in,
or I ended up going to graduate school
in the South Chicago.
I mean,
night and day.
I was sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure of that.
Well,
that brings us to this sort of
the next section of your life.
He graduated in 1964 from Oregon State.
How did you decide what you're going to do next?
Well, I had decided back in,
in my junior year when I got out of the Navy,
that out of the NRTC program,
that I wanted to go on to,
to get a degree of PhD in physics,
and,
and do research,
and work at research labs,
so I really liked that.
And so I applied to graduate school.
And I had,
was interested in that,
uh,
after getting away from the West Coast,
so applied to the Irish Chicago,
and a couple of schools out of the West here.
I remember,
like Berkeley and University of Washington.
And I got accepted by the University of Chicago,
and they offered me a research of fellowship
and a citizenship.
So that covered the education,
of course they paid the tuition to.
So I was able to go to the University of Chicago,
you know,
asked about how I finished,
we saved up a little money.
But that's why I met my wife, too,
as I had Chicago.
And in 1966.
So,
it was,
it was a play,
I chose Chicago,
it's one of the reasons it's a good school.
And,
the financial aid package was very generous, I thought.
And it was a different part of the country.
It was interesting to,
you know,
move out to another part of the country.
And what's certainly different,
I mean, it was a real lesson to me.
Never having been to Chicago.
I didn't interview the school where he liked that.
I got accepted,
at a rule of 57 Dodge Station,
working at the time.
I loaded up all my stuff,
and drove across Montana,
and I'm down into Chicago.
And,
right there,
and I wondered,
you know,
I'm going to survive,
because it's a very different environment.
Yeah.
Tell me about that transition.
You're living in a major city,
living in a kind of a rough part of a major city.
Yeah.
It was,
you know,
the South Chicago was in a transition
from,
a relatively quite Polish Irish community
to primarily black or African American.
And there was,
all those problems associated with that
in terms of, you know,
cultural classes,
and so you,
you would see that frequently,
and there's a lot of racism on both sides,
particularly as,
as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as,
as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as, as the population,
and the population profile,
and demographic change.
And these neighborhoods,
there was a lot of trouble.
And there,
with people's minds anyhow.
And so it was an interesting thing.
Of course, it's not exposed to an organ at all.
You would have never had any idea.
And so it was a joint talent, Corvalce,
with very few minorities.
At least at that time, go to Chicago
or in South Chicago, somebody like me,
a white person was a minority.
And it was a real experience.
And it gives you a perspective on how minorities
in this country, with the kinds of perceptions they
must have, and some of their populations, I guess,
what causes trouble and anxieties.
But it's a good lesson, I like, for everybody.
Well, the University of Virginia, too,
is a world-class university, University of Chicago,
very high-powered in the sciences.
Tell me a little bit about that atmosphere that you came into
at that point.
It was a very competitive, I mean,
the students for all, you know, very, very bright.
I remember the Chairman told me that everybody in the class
had GRE scores in the 98% talent above.
And they were all real, really, really successful students.
It was a very competitive.
Fortunately, I, with my background at Orange States,
for me in Good City, I had no problems with the academics
and the work at Chicago, and it was one well,
and made the normal course events and graduated
in six, seven years with a PhD.
It was a typical time for physics in those days at Chicago.
I think some of the other majors take, it was less time,
but so I graduated in the early 1970s with a PhD.
I want to ask you about a couple of people that were there,
I believe, when you were there, that are big names of the first
as an Indian fellow, Superb onion and Chandra Shikar.
Absolutely, he's a great professor.
I had him for a couple of classes, actually,
and statistical physics and atomic molecular physics,
quantum mechanics, advanced quantum mechanics.
I mean, he was a brilliant teacher, and he would come in
and just turn his lecture and he had perfect handwriting on the board.
This was the days of chalk boards, none of this,
none of this stuff, and no overhead projections,
that sort of thing, was the classical blackboard
where you sight him up and down and fill up a room with that.
And he would start precisely on time and finish precisely
on time, noise with the coherent message.
And as last few minutes would be a summary,
and then you could write all the summaries down on your notes.
And then you would have the important elements of the conversation
and the talk.
So, no, he's a brilliant professor.
Really nice person.
I came as Robert Muller, I came on the Nobel Prize in 1966,
while you were there, you remember that?
Yes, and I knew Robert Muller,
he was in the same building as why he did my research,
and I would see him frequently.
He was an interesting man, a brilliant, brilliant chemist
physicist, and he took from molecular physics,
and he had a whole bunch of students, and then,
post, I see, he had a large enterprise in those days,
doing, in fact, classical speed, theoretical physics,
and so on.
But he was a real quiet man, and he was already all
by the time I got to know him, and I didn't have any classes
from him.
But he didn't teach much.
He was all up to 100% research, and, of course,
trapped in a lot, because he was a world-favorite,
but he had a dozens of people working in his laboratories,
and they rire some hall there,
if the University of Calgary was there.
Well, it sounds like it tremendously enriching
environment, and if you tell me about this,
or the progression of your academic courses,
there, your research time.
Yeah, I worked, I had my first shoot up there,
and then the fall of the 64, I was assigned
to work for Professor Mark Ingram, who did
mass spectrometry and in chemical physics,
and various sorts of instrumentations
looking at properties of the topic, and like the systems.
And I worked in his lab as a research assistant
for the first couple years, and in Chicago,
they had a, you had to take physics courses,
and then think of that nature as well as preparing
for what they call an interesting exam,
or the candidate exam.
We usually took that at the starting year,
and the fall of your second year.
That was a very, very hard test, the qualifier.
And so the first year graduate students
would spend huge amounts of time studying old tests
and problems, because there was a three-day test,
you know, with all problems.
I mean, it was another small little guess
that was all problems to solve, and all areas of physics.
And so you had to be well prepared, and so on.
Unfortunately, I passed out the first time through,
and I was able to get my research started,
and I was also a test for a lot of people
didn't make it the first time they'd have to take away
six months of year and take it again.
And then a lot, and some people just laughed,
it was so daunting that they just laughed.
But that's like a lot of universities
have those sort of qualifying exams,
and it's a hurdle at all, all people starting
for an advanced degree have to overcome.
But it was, it was taxing, it occupied a huge amount
of your time, and it was a study, and then
to learn a material about it to pass those exams.
It was rewarding, too, because there was a focus
of your attention, and you really did learn a lot.
I mean, if you took the right attitude,
so it was been a very, very beneficial process,
as far as I can say.
So I'm in favor of difficult exams.
I think that it focuses as one's attention,
and it enables you to really, really do the learns
of what's the thing as well.
Then I worked up, if I passed this qualifier exam,
then you could start a PhD program.
You couldn't formally struggle to be passed
at qualifiers, so you have to find some professors
that were taking on, and then you have some research project
that you wanted to do.
And I chose to say where the guy had worked
as a research assistant, because I was interested
in the physics and then in the programs that he had.
And he also used a really nice generous man,
and he had a, you know, a fire-shaped graduate student
in a couple postdocs, and it was a good learning environment.
So I elected to stay there and worked on some problems
and in full runization.
We had machines that would generate vacuumals
for a while of radiation, and use that radiation
with monocrovers, dispersant, and use that radiation
to study atomic and molecular systems, you know,
ionize them, and use the mass spectrometer
or electron spectrovers depending on
to analyze those reaction products from the ionization process.
And it's so that things like cross-sections,
and so forth, for the reactions,
photon, atom, and molecule reactions.
And my work that did was to look at ionization processes
in rare earth elements, the lanthanides,
so things like erropium and terbium, erbium,
and things of that nature.
We generated ovens, they're all metals,
that room temperature, so you have to make an oven,
and generate a atomic beam, all this is in vacuum, of course.
The generate a beam of those, and intersect that beam
with the light beam, and an ionization process,
you start knocking off electrons.
And you can melt it, and then the ion product
is a function of wavelength of a light,
and it determines its ionization potential,
so we measured some of the ionization processes
of these rare earth elements, which hadn't been done,
because it was prior to its difficult.
So it's so good people didn't launch spectroscopy,
others, and didn't much, got much more accurate results,
but those kind of experiments, and it was sort of a lot of fun.
You had to build, learn how to build ovens,
all high temperature ovens, and intersect that,
all in a vacuum system, and intersect that with a light beam,
and get the mass of a trotter, which is a relatively large instrument
to measure the ion products.
Then we also did some work with organic molecules,
which were a lot easier, you just look at them,
they make a big rise, and you can get a molecular beam
fairly straightforward, for more organic molecules,
and study their processes, and look at their dissociation processes,
and well, so we did studies of various kinds of molecules
so we would look at their ionizations
while there's a dissociation processes.
How independent were you in developing these topics?
Was it something where you went to your mentor
with this idea, or was it the kind of yetto way around?
No, you had to, in what was the professor,
and you had to develop your own topic,
and then convince him that this was something to do,
and he would support, and that's what I did.
I was interested in these rare earths,
because there was some interest in the scientific community
about some of their ionization properties,
and also some of the internal intake properties
of some of the organic molecules we studied.
People were interested in their internal processes,
and measuring their energies, if you will.
And because the internal energies of these molecules
determine how they combine with others, and that's all on.
And so there was interest in a given things called
the heats of formation of molecular ions,
and so forth that we did some studies on systems
that were of interest for the kinds of chemistry,
because that told you the energy balances
in these ion molecule reactions.
So we were engaged in that kind of research
using these four ionization tools.
And those days that four ionization studies was hard,
because you had to have laboratory light sources,
so these would be discharges, pulse discharges,
with a high electrical pulse, and a capillary tube filled
with a rare gas, usually, or hydrogen, in some cases.
And a light helium, and then you generate the helium
with get excited and generate molecular helium,
which would then dissociate, because helium
was an inner gas that doesn't form a molecule,
except in excited states.
And that dissociation process, it's a maturation
in the far old devilot.
So we'd use that radiation, and dispersal
with the monochromorium, and sodium,
or these atoms, and then the ion molecules as well.
But it's subsequent, you know, by the time I left grader school,
and in late 60s, and that's certainly now,
and 70s on, do all in the synchrotron radiation,
and also laser sources of the total supply of that.
To do what we did in those days,
now you go to synchrotron most likely,
it would be fairly straightforward.
But it was hard at that in those days,
because of the technology available,
we were limited to laboratory light sources.
Now there's the synchrotron radiation sources
throughout the world.
In fact, I worked at the National Institute of Standards
and Technology, I was the one who reasons
they have a small synchrotron radiation source
at the Institute, and we use that for atomic and electric
physics studies.
Same kinds of basic technologies
as I used in graduate school, and so having these
discharge light sources like a neon ball, if you will,
you have these big machines that generate radiation
from cyclic trion radiation.
But there's faric graduate school goals,
you had to devise your own projects,
and then you had to publish,
and then Chicago had a requirement
at that time that your thesis had to be published
in the peer review literature.
So I had to prepare an article
for the German chemical physics,
and then once that was accepted, that was,
then you escaped the rigors
of after right of formal thesis
that paper that your road got accepted
in a peer review journal was basically your thesis.
He just bound that, and that was it.
And then you were not, after I wore these tedious
thing in her page, ceases,
and there's something like some places required.
I thought it was a good idea, because if you start to think
about it, that's what you want, your researchers
to do is be able to publish in the peer review literature.
So that, I thought that was always a clever
and incessible criteria.
And so something you had to achieve.
But at least as graduate student, you're guaranteed
at least having one publication,
if you're going to get your degree.
Whether any folks within the department
that enriches being a foreign to you or memorable,
besides eagering?
Oh yeah, I had some classes from a famous scientist,
Greg Evans, the Winsel, and he was a very, very good teacher,
a no-world gentleman, I think, a swishard German,
and he was one of the founders of the quantum
letter dynamics, back in the 40s, and he was a teacher
at Professor at Chicago at that time.
And also, I learned a lot from the technical staff
and the physics department of the states.
They had a wonderful electronic engineer
that I worked with, developed, and built an equipment,
and electronics equipment.
They had some wonderful people,
and the machine shop, because we had to make our own equipment.
We didn't go to a catalog and buy a mass spectrometer,
a monochromor, you made it yourself.
And so I learned machine techniques,
and also got to be a fairly good heliarch welder,
because we'd weld the chambers to go back
and chambers together, and that sort of thing.
And the guys in the shop would teach you to do all that stuff.
So I thought it was fascinating.
I got to do all kinds of things that got paid for
as a student that I really enjoyed doing.
It was a wonderful experience.
I was here at Chicago, just in my mind,
really, really, really, really good.
And additionally, getting a family started,
and so on, it was a wonderful learning experience.
Did you do any teaching?
Occasionally, I would teach a course,
but not for undergraduates.
I teach some courses, and people preparing
for the basic exam with a qualifying exam.
And assist in some of the graduate courses.
But I never, I was never a teaching assistant ship
and a sense of teaching the undergraduate courses,
and so forth.
I avoided that.
And I was able to have a research assistant ship
or work in the lab, and never got so much involved
on the teaching side.
Tell me about meeting Ruth, 1966.
Well, that was interesting.
So I was driving out to go to my sister's wedding,
and she, I was going to bring an Indian friend
of mine from India.
A man and was his name.
And he was going to ride with me.
And we were going to share expenses.
Well, he was a far clever businessman, and I was.
And he determined, since I had that,
it was a totally dodged stationery of the time.
It was room for others.
He went around, I'd been noticed to me,
and solicited other writers, to go parts of the trip.
One guy came all the way to Eugene.
I dropped him off on Eugene, but the Ruth
rude with us with a friend to Cheyenne, Wyoming.
And we were at him off there, and I don't mean
and had some financial reasons.
I don't know what it was.
And so I got to be a career of people
across the country to go on this trip.
But the men figure, I think, men are figures.
He saved us off a lot of money.
And it's true that they experienced.
So that's how I met Ruth and when I got back to Chicago.
So I've seen her, and turned out she lived in that,
and a place where I lived in an international house
in Chicago, so we got together and she got married.
And she was a student.
She was an undergraduate at the time.
And he said he started a family.
And daughter was born there, or son was born there too.
And in Chicago, in Chicago, in Chicago.
So what was that like being a family man
and a student at the same time?
It worked out pretty well.
Fortunately, my wife was real capable.
And she worked at a correspondence school.
They're called the American School.
In fact, it was a block away from our apartment,
where we went up, and so she could go get papers
and great papers, and work on these correspondence courses.
And that turned out a source of income, and do that at home.
She didn't have to leave him in, so the trial was washed at home.
And we lived in student housing that was right
on campus, in the early close.
So that's that worked out well.
Well, you were in Chicago during turbulent times.
But 68 Democratic convention is well known as being
sort of an iconic moment for that time period
in that location.
Do you have any memories of it?
It was awful.
Everybody's bad behavior contributed to a really awfully
event.
I mean, nothing, no one can be proud of those days in my mind.
And the protesters are out of line.
But in the Chicago case, the police's response
were totally out of line.
And I think it was characterized as a police riot.
And I think that's about right.
And I'm a pretty conservative fellow.
But I mean, the Chicago cops were just not the best.
I hope they've changed over the years.
But you know, I got shaken down twice in my use of Chicago,
because I had an out of state play license plate by cops.
And you want to bribe for letting me off.
And it was not pleasant.
I mean, but that's the way it was.
And so it was not all cops, obviously.
But it was a corruption in there.
They were not nice to the protesters in those days.
In fact, I was done never went up town
to the world that the convention was.
But I was just walking back from the lab one night.
And there's some cop cars destroying down there by the university,
looking for students to harass.
And they were, you know, there was a cop,
a fellow, but I could tell it was a cop by their playing
clothesman.
And they were thinking about harassing me.
They're striking by me as I was walking.
And really checking me out.
And I could tell that they were not thinking
good thoughts.
They were down in the south side.
And I suspect they wanted to get it on the actions
that comrades were having downtown.
And I didn't like that that the Chicago cops at that time
I had to not a lot of respect for them,
because of my personal experiences.
Well, between work in family probably not a lot of free time,
but I'm wondering if there's anything about Chicago
that made a big impact on the social or cultural way.
There was a lot of cultural activities.
And as a student, you don't have a lot of money,
but there are a lot of inexpensive things to do.
The University of Chicago is not far from Lake Michigan.
And so you can just walk out of the lake
and have some beaches.
And so forth, there was a Chicago Museum of Science
industry was very close to the campus.
And that was a wonderful museum.
And we'd go there frequently.
And they had forest preserves and the outskirts of Chicago.
So we had big parks.
And so Ruth and I, and it's been time there
and it was particularly on the summer.
So if you wouldn't go out there and just talk a little bit.
It's a couple of the guys I worked with in the machine
ists and the case of go fishing
and do something that made you too.
So it's an interesting environment, Chicago.
It's a very different from here.
And it was a real cultural shot.
Another big thing.
The Y57 Dodge Land drove out had a,
it was an organ car, right?
And so the tires were bald.
And the battery was ancient.
And the SISI was getting cold in November.
Car went start and the first time
it got a little snow on the street.
You couldn't go anywhere because the tires had no tread.
And of course, I had a light wind break kind of jacket.
And it got cold.
And so that November December was a happy time.
I had to get the car out of the hood running in the litter time.
And I think going the roads as well
is get some clothes that were appropriate for that.
That tend to be an environment when the wind's halting.
So that was a real, real, real shocker.
And my first quarter I had to live in in Chicago
I was living in an apartment in about 20 or 30
blocks from what the university was.
So I had to drive back and forth to school.
And I soon rectified that I got a room
at the International House for the second, third quarter
is that the first year.
And we'll see if we'll walk back and forth
to campus because driving in the winter with an older car
is not the best way to get around.
It was in terrible inconvenience.
And also parking problems and cities of this bad move.
Of course, I hadn't realized that my first
appliance Chicago had been smart to arrange housing
in advance.
I assume it was like pervall, if you could just
find an apartment, you know, a lot of big cities.
What wasn't in the case?
Apartments, the living in the ranch, where it will scare us.
So it took me a few days after when I arrived,
I'd say no tell or someplace, for a few days
and I'd like to find an apartment in a bus.
Quite far, actually, far from the university.
Interesting learning experience.
Well, sort of the continuing topic of cultural shifts
finished up in 1971 in Chicago and went to Alabama.
Tell me about that.
Well, I thought I wanted to be a teaching profession.
And a friend of mine, former graduate of student
graduated, went to the University of Alabama
and got a pretty good grant to get his research set up.
And so they recruited me as well to come down
and get a research project started at Vanderbilt with them
and also with a couple of companies.
And decided I was going to be with Santa and Doyle,
or I was called Essos or something, and those days out
in New Jersey.
They offered me a job as well, but it had been an area
in New Jersey, I didn't think much of.
Besides, I wanted to give teaching a go.
So I took a job as an assistant professor at the University of Alabama.
So we lived in Tuscosse, Alabama for 1970 to the 78 years,
I guess, it was.
And then I went on sabbatical leave at the Bureau of Standards
that was called that in Maryland.
And then they offered me a job.
And I decided that the National Bureau of Standards
was, in the back teaching.
Because the research opportunities were far better.
Because it was a struggle.
Alabama is a good school, it's like in the other state school.
But in those states, it was hard to raise money.
And we fought a difficult to raise money
from the foundations and so forth.
And now, Obama, to get our research started.
We raised some, we were fairly successful.
Let's turn to my end of Jason, and I was very, very, very difficult.
He spent a lot of time just trying to raise money
and then so on.
And also the teaching mode was fairly heavy, compared to most universities.
It was two courses.
You had to have six contact hours a quarter.
And that didn't leave a lot of time for your research.
You just had to be in there all hours of the day and night.
So it was not the best research environment.
It was at the University of Chicago, I was like,
I just student professors taught one course, two out of the three
quarters, one quarter they taught, nothing.
I mean, they didn't have any teaching obligations.
So I mean, there's a big difference between the research universities
in your average state university.
I might just still have way of more state universities
that professors will have at least two courses.
And that's very time-consuming.
And so the bureau standards was not sabbatical leave.
Of course, there's no teaching and they were fairly well funded,
compared to what was at the Alabama.
And it was funded directly by the government for government programs.
And so eventually I had gotten a position
where I could raise a lot of money, you know,
because the NBS even in the government organization,
we did do work for other government agencies.
And so we did had programs that in NASA and NOAA,
the Department of Defense supported.
So I raised a lot, we raised a lot of money from those agencies
before, you know, well-defined programs,
rather than trying some fundamental research program
like at National Science Foundation.
So it was a very different environment.
And I actually sort of liked a lot better.
So it was the project, the research topic in Alabama,
was that maybe it mostly makes the extension
of what you had been doing in Chicago?
Yeah, so I built a smaller version of what we had in Chicago
and we were going to do some work on rare earths.
We've got started on that.
And then they'll small organic molecules.
And I did just gotten that project started
when I went on sabbatical leave.
And originally, I went on sabbatical leave.
It was a, some of you gave it a donation.
Or some money came up somehow.
They were going to totally run away
to physics building.
Everybody's going to have to move out.
All of us are going to be closed down.
So I said, well, we're other than just sitting here for a year.
I had an offer, had had an offer to go to Maryland
to the National Bureau of Standards to work with a team there.
And the same kind of work photo ionization studies.
And so I said, well, let's take this back leave.
So I went to work for them.
Just as an olisabeth leave at the Bureau of Standards.
And then that first year, I still be a pay by Alabama.
And the National Bureau of Standards
sent them some money to pay for my time.
It's called inner governmental personal act of pointy.
And so I spent the first year there.
Then I was going to go back.
We were going to go back to Alabama.
Because we liked it.
They were going to have nice houses.
We'd build a nice house and so forth.
But they didn't get done with the renovation.
They've got gone.
So they're going to be out of second year.
So they had asked me if I would like to stay second year
at the Bureau of Standards.
I said, OK, so it worked out good.
Then sometimes during the second year, early in the second year,
they offered me a staff position at the Bureau of Standards,
which was actually doubled my salary.
And then we were in Glen Baldwin and a research program.
I really liked and really had high international profile.
And worked with a buttery, some really top people.
And it was all research.
And there was no teaching.
And no committees.
And none of this, a lot of fundraising in those days.
So it was a real opportunity I thought.
And so I elected to stay at the Bureau of Standards.
And so we just never went back to Alabama.
But that was nothing tension, or we first went to the Gators
for Maryland, for the Bureau of Standards, and it was located.
What was your impression of the South when you were there?
I was like good, it was that the weather's awful.
I never got used to it.
You know, the starts in May, the hot humidity and it would be in the 90s.
And you would, you know, by human, I mean, 90 percent humidity.
Not people here get off sight if it's 40 percent humidity.
But I mean, it would be very, very humid.
And it's hard to get used to.
I never really did.
It was everything in your house, your carvings, air conditioning.
You'd turn that air conditioning on and wait,
mainly like I say, or sometimes something by June,
and it would just be on until October.
I mean, it was, to me, it was very,
but now the natives, people growing up in that,
they don't seem to, they don't seem to bother,
but they have become accustomed to a bite.
I never really climbed the ties to that hot humidity.
So that's the only thing I do like about the people more nice.
The Tesla is a loving little town.
It's no say it was a smaller town bigger than Corvallas,
but it was still a college town, basically.
And of course now, it's a subsequently, a lot bigger.
They put a car factory Mercedes in one of those companies,
put a assembly plant there and an Alabama.
That's not far away.
And so it's a lot of industrialization.
So it's a change in Barb, just like a lot of college
sometimes.
How about the culture of the area?
It was very different.
I mean, you know, you normally think of a South
as being real racist.
Well, they had their, their little vestiges of segregation,
but it was, to me, was less harsh in those terms.
And what I used to see in Chicago was really ugly.
I mind, in fact, the first department I ran at the guy
says, I'll give you real, real good deal
because I want a white guy live in here.
Well, I think I didn't, I had no idea what the customer
wanted to know about, I'll take the deal
because I didn't need to replace the state.
This was good, I hadn't arranged it at housing.
But they were, they were, there were different racism
that you could have served in there.
You'd see some of that in Alabama,
but not to the extent, the reason that seemed more harmonious
to me than the racial relations in Chicago.
That's the blacks and the whites in the South.
Now that other people probably have a different perspective,
I know, but I mean, I didn't see the harshness
that I would, and they'll work to things
that you press that I saw in Chicago.
That's just one man's take on the other people,
but I think that would probably be a different take on it.
Well, one thing I'm sure that was indescapable,
while you were there was, was called football.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, one, three national championships
during your time at Barbrain is the coach.
Yeah, they take football real seriously in the South.
I mean, the average were going,
I mean, they just live and die.
And then, you know, place like Texas, too.
I mean, just in Mississippi,
the Louisiana, all of them, it is the sport.
And they really take it seriously.
And Alabama has this constant feud with Auburn,
which is sort of, Auburn sort of the quote
of work in the state is, it's a land practice rule.
I think, it's Auburn, because it's in the city of Auburn.
But there's a fierce rivalry.
And it's been going off for years and years,
and they, and it comes apart a couple.
So even people who don't go to the schools,
they're an Auburn and Alabama fan,
and, you know, where they can be a mill worker, whatever, you know,
and they'll have their loves, these sort of unknowingly.
I see some of that in Oregon, but it's not, it's not,
it's like, it's just, it's pro-nails.
But they do take football seriously.
And Barbrain was a really revered person.
I mean, they have a lot of club.
I think.
For sure.
Well, you mentioned it's sabbatical and you started
up full-time at the National Bureau of Standards in 1980.
So I guess you can tell me a little bit about moving
to the DC area and settling in, and then your first position
in the physicist and the radiation physics division.
Yeah, I was, I liked it.
I liked it.
The climate marons a little bit.
You get, you call winners in marons.
You get more diversity.
It's Alabama.
It's hot most of the time, even all you around.
But the marons, it's, it's you wouldn't hot
on the summer time, which cools down the fall on the winter,
you get snow and so on.
So we first year, we lived in an apartment,
and maybe my wife and my kids were like that.
So we bought a house.
I probably has offered a job and bought a house
and lived in the same place for 1980 on.
And so I, I kind of tried to like it as a,
Washington DC area is a culture of a diverse
and very, very interesting region.
And it's, some war battle fields, you know,
in Gettysburg and Teetham will run all those
or hours so drive away from where we lived in Gettysburg.
And those are all very interesting.
And well done by the National Park Service
in terms of historical presentations.
So I really enjoyed that.
We enjoyed the museums downtown, the Smithsonian Museum,
so it just, it's simply the best there is.
And that's all free.
And, you know, from where we were 30 minutes away,
and I'll take the train down the other foot of subway
system, and we would close the terminals of the subway lines
with it, it used to be in the end down if you wanted.
So the cultural, cultural things are immense,
and we would get the season tickets to the,
to some orchestra arrangements at the Kennedy Center.
And that was always great.
Crowd would be great.
I mean, it's a traffic soft, downtown Washington.
But it was a nice place to live.
I enjoyed the experience of great deal.
And, you know, there were so, the negative sides
is the weather, and it's also very, very crowded.
The roads to Washington, Bellway, and it's truly awful.
And the roadway, we were not too far from the interstate 270,
which runs out of north of northwest to out of Washington,
and it's a, it's an emissary busy road
because all the commuter traffic back for the DC,
and from the Maryland suburbs at the work downtown,
and it, it's 14 lanes in places.
It's seven lanes each way with the feeder.
It's just awful.
And you get on out of the boat for the bumper,
all those lanes, and rush out.
If you, off rush out, it's busy.
We would just, sometimes, listen,
we bought a boat that we kept over on the Chesapeake,
and even on Saturday morning, getting over to the Chesapeake,
which is anapolis, near anapolis, was to have been an easy hour,
hour and a half drive, sometimes we've lost a lot longer
because we're just traffic on Saturday morning.
So it's a very, very crowded.
That's one of the reasons when we retired,
we were not going to live in the DC suburbs,
and we ended up out here in Stead,
and I think it was an incision.
We both were really glad we made, mainly the living conditions.
And the coast like here is the, you know,
and things in the DC suburbs are really superb,
but the crowded in Stead and the weather
are really contrary to my particular life.
So some people, I can of course, you know,
that's not what I like.
So we enjoy the weather and the environment here much better.
We'll tell you about the prevention of your working.
I was first hired at,
when I was post-docing,
I was very, not really post-docing though.
I was working as a guest scientist there,
a first year of our civil professor at Alabama.
I worked in a laboratory with a guy named Henry Rosenstock
and Roger Stockbauer.
We were very well-known in chemical physics
for doing internal structures of molecules.
So the energetic some molecules.
So we worked with some techniques using
of professional photo-1, electro-inspectroscopy,
studying molecular processes and small molecules.
Then at that first year also they were getting started
on the synchrotrophysic,
and it's the nest,
and the NBS has a small electron synchrotron,
which generates light,
a total of all light.
They were getting a project started using
synchrotron radiation for photo-electrons
by trustees.
So I joined on with Roger Stockbauer
and a team from Argon, Joe Deamer and his team at Argon
National Laboratory.
Bill Electrons by Tromber System that was able
to angely resolve the electrons coming off
from an ionization process and atoms
with many small molecules.
So we built that system for a year, I was there,
and then there was another reason for me
to stay a second year and then basically take a job
because that apparatus was just coming into fruition
in terms of the spot activity.
So we were able to do some really, really, really interesting things
and new kinds of studies using synchrotron radiation
and the electrons by Tromber are doing angle-resolved
photo-electronization studies.
So some of the first of that type in the world,
and it was very well received on this community.
So we did that and then build a successfully
build new instruments in terms of four electrons
with trust to be in an angle-resolved
and participated in illustrative space
and a few other kinds of experience experiments.
And so the laboratory experiments that I first
got started going with there, we quit all that all together
and collected lives and closed down to make
all the photo-electronization out of work
that was done with the synchrotron.
And that's where I was hired as when they offered me
the staff position was to work on the team of scientists
working on the call of psychotron ultraviolet radiation facility
at the NPS and in 1980, you're 80,
you want to change the name from NPS to NIST.
So it's the same organization with these Congress
in there, infinite wisdom decided to change the name.
Reflected a little different mission, I guess,
was the idea, like changing orders to take college
ordering to state university.
That's sort of the thing in that.
Nothing fundamentally changed,
it's just, after we do all the letterhead and door signs.
But it's so I worked in that operation for about five years,
as a research physicist in the radiation physics division,
and with the part of our physics group
under the guineamed Robert Matton,
who was in charge of the synchrotron,
and a very well-known optical person,
the monocholar design, so forth.
So it was a wonderful experience working with the scientists there.
And the other nice thing about NIST,
I'll call it that, that's his name now,
is that it's in Washington DC area.
So you get a continued tour touring of a really well-known
scientist from throughout the world.
This is one thing I missed in Alabama.
You have to really work out to get to Tusklyce,
but everybody comes through Washington DC
and they would visit NIST in those days.
And we also collaborated with a team of scientists
on these photo-wechron works from England,
and John West from Darsbury,
laboratory in England, Keith Kotlin,
from Redding University in England.
Another people in our programs,
and in fact, I would then go to England
and work on the six trophies,
so the Darsbury and the United Kingdom and the later stages,
we transferred it over the instrumentation that we built it.
NIST, new photo-wechron, so across the country,
we transported it to England.
This was a big piece of equipment, many tons,
and it transferred it to the Darsbury laboratory
and near up near Manchester,
Darsbury is a small town.
And then the slide would perform,
we'd do some work over there as well,
with my English colleagues.
So it was a real nice collaboration between
the Darsbury and the Darsbury laboratory.
So of course, I made good friends who we still have to this day
with the English colleague, got defensive time,
and in other central facilities,
in France and other places as well, to visit.
It was a very, very rewarding time-scientific,
and a lot of travel and interesting people.
That was one of the nice things I really enjoyed about NIST,
was the depth of the world.
NIST was the depth of the people we've worked with,
and so the best people from all over the world.
We had guests from France, China,
Japan, all over, and to come to work on our laboratories,
and that was a extremely rewarding scientific time.
And so I worked on those six-chron-ray-shakes
where I must have told the mid-1980s,
85, or 86, something like that.
And I was offered a job in another division,
as a group leader,
there was a division that was having some personal problems,
and had a lot of difficulties.
As I said, take over a group that needed some attention,
and then they'd call it a specter-ready-art review,
I guess it was the name of it.
So it became a group leader, which is the most level main
position of the NIST.
And I think about 1986, something like that, I don't know.
And I worked on that division.
It was called the Radiometric Physics Division,
and it was, it's job was to do all the optical measurements,
or most of the optical measurements for this country.
It's standards.
They did everything from standard light bulbs.
You know, when you buy light bulbs,
the store will have a loom and rating on it,
so we maintain those standards in the standard of the candellas,
as well as optical temperature measurements.
So we developed that division, as well as maintain all those standards,
as well as to develop the technology to improve the standards.
So we worked a lot with the industry,
to collaborate with industrial partners,
to develop better measurement techniques to help
product quality and reliability on the assembly.
It comes like code act, 3M,
that do have a lot of optical measurement problems.
For example, 3M makes a lot of white paper.
I think that makes sure you need reflective standards,
and how you measure all that.
And so on and I spent time with helping code act,
to collaborate measuring processes and optical processes
for properly making your measuring film.
They had a lot of instruments.
And in those days, those are the film days.
The old technologies changed.
But then on LEDs,
and other kinds of sources, light sources that became available,
we had to develop the technology to properly characterize those.
And I imagine, because they were a little different,
little different needs in your index and bulbs and fluorescent bulbs.
And so our division, the work with industry,
to develop the right strategy to making a reliable and consistent measurement.
It became industry standards,
and how you measure an LED's property and so on.
And so that's the job that division.
I eventually became the division chief of that division.
I remember when that was in that late-eatory night,
and that's when I retired in 2007.
It was a chief of the changes to the name
and the optical technology division.
Since I've less than subsequently changed this name again,
there have been another reorganization.
But it's basically the same division.
It's now called sensor science division or something of that nature.
So I was able to then be in charge of all these measurement techniques
and develop, develop work for early-covered agencies.
And that was very rewarding.
I enjoyed that.
We had projects back in the mid-80s.
The effect was on my first job as a group leader in specter radiometry.
The defense department was having problems characterizing
very low-level infrared sensors that are used for satellite purposes.
And that's a security program.
And they had to be sensors that were calibrated at very, very low temperatures.
Because they were sensors that would look at the background
and space looking at a missile threat.
That sort of thing.
And so they would operate really well in terms of that.
And we calibrated and they made a measurement assurance.
They were seeing what they told you they were seeing.
And we developed techniques to calibrate things that five degrees
of colour and just a little bit of absolute zero.
Very little temperatures.
And called low background infrared calibrational cell.
So it's that was a real challenge technically.
And that's facility cell.
And in a place being used to characterize very low level background
sort of signals.
And sensor systems for primarily duty.
But occasionally NASA and other government agencies have
needs for characterizing very low background sources.
Things are going to operate in space primarily.
So that was a fun project.
And development of technology and capabilities for the department of defense.
So they of course would pay for it.
Department of Defense and pay painless for it.
We're doing this work.
And so we risked a lot of projects for NOAA.
And NASA for the support.
It's a weird optical division.
Supporting satellite technology.
You see these pictures of the colour pictures of the earth.
You see pictures of the oceans.
Whether they're using cameras on spacecraft to measure ocean properties.
All those cameras and devices have to be calibrated.
They're specterary, yonder system basically flying around the space.
Looking at the spectral content of light coming back from the earth.
The earth from the surface reflected.
And that tells you about the properties of the vegetation on the case of the oceans.
The plank and then the carbon content of the ocean.
So we work with NASA to develop calibration strategies to calibrate the satellites.
And then involves building calibration systems for the satellites before they are launched.
And then trying to build systems so they can verify their operation while in flight.
And that tells, for example, the satellite's looking at standard sources.
In fact, there's a, we have one of the big projects was to have a,
it was a buoy system out there.
And Lenin and Hawaiian Islands that measures the light coming out of the ocean.
They call it the upwelling radius of the ocean.
So it's reflected light from the sun.
Going back up.
And that's what the spacecraft will see.
You see, you'll see the light coming off the ocean.
So that's measured out in Hawaii.
So the spacecraft will have a,
and it'll fly over and give them the same old changes in the measurement.
We can tell what it is that the Earth's surface of the water surface, if you will.
And the satellite then can check its calibration.
And that's been a mind-blowing project.
In fact, I'm still consulting someone that particular project.
Well, we have one of the projects to develop the other projects development.
Calibration, precision, and measurement procedures.
A whole range of sensor systems for the, for the,
the no-one NASA project because it was an interesting department.
Another, another agencies that, that have a secure program.
So they have to be a very sophisticated sensor systems.
We work with them on that as well.
Let's see, I, or whatever, you know, they, they have a sensor program.
So we were a government agency that would help work with them to,
to develop their sensor measurement capabilities.
Well, as I've listened to you described,
they said a couple of things occur to me in everyone.
It sounds like it's a pretty big shift when you, when you switch gears to,
to the radiation physics division.
Or to the, sorry, the great, the spectral radio,
oh, I'm a spectrary elementary group.
If I'm doing sort of this more fundamental research,
you're dealing with for it to this thing.
I was a big shift from a fundamental research to a applied research.
But the underlying, the theme was, it was all light measuring.
And, and manipulation controlling light.
And it's a, you're using light as a source.
So you have to build monochrombers and build detectors of radiological radiation,
and so on.
So, and then in radiometry, the concentration is not on the use of the light,
but of measuring the light and characterizing, you see.
In characterizing the sensors so that someone else can,
you know, quickly determine what they're, what they're measuring.
And in the case of the satellites,
what they'll want to know is what the, what the,
the radiation is at one way that compared to another.
And, and the one and all that pretty accurately,
so that those ratios, those wavelengths will tell you,
for example, the plank of concentration.
And so, it's, it's all optics of some sort of,
or dealing with like a magnetic radiation,
but it's, it's a different emphasis.
And you actually write the,
reometry division was a,
a very applied on the measurement and the measurement technology.
And development is sources as well as the,
you know,
you characterization of these things.
Where's the,
the second generation, which was,
it was the fundamental driver was trying to understand
some basic features of atomic and lighter of physics.
You know, how molecules are nice and dissociate somewhat.
Yeah.
It's also the application of science,
to a very wide variety of projects,
several which apparently involve some national security implications
that must develop the tremendous fun area.
Yeah, it is.
And very diverse, I mean,
and we had colleagues,
our labs and boulders, there was a whole group of divisions
that was just concentrated on developing techniques for measuring laser
and laser power.
And that, you know, we played with them too.
It was fascinating.
And so it was a, it was a real learning experience.
And it was also a lot of fun.
And you know, the highest level is either the best people doing this,
anywhere.
Mike, our organization had, you know,
in terms of the national labs.
It was probably, you know,
one of the premier national labs in the world
in terms of the quality of its research and
calibration and development.
So it was a real, you know, really a lot of fun
and it was a very rewarding and intellectually.
And again, it's the people.
I mean, it's really the best for these were the best people
and these fields are anywhere.
So it was a very enjoyable time.
It's a job that I hope everybody can get.
I mean, a job in the sense that you go to work
and you really love it.
And you, you don't try to avoid working on it.
It's, it's fun to be there.
I really feel fortunate in that regard.
I've got myself in a career where work was really fun.
It was financially rewarding.
And but it was, it was enjoyable to do.
And not, some people I under you talked to there.
They were always discriminable about the working.
I would never say that I truly enjoyed my career for everything.
Grad school at Oregon State.
I enjoyed being a student.
I enjoyed graduate school.
I enjoyed being the national team of state and technology as well.
Yeah.
Good answer anymore with that.
What was your family up to during the DC era at DC years?
You're wife and children?
My wife worked at several occupations.
She ran daycare at home for a while.
But then she went back to school to hop and John Hopkins,
and got her master's degree in counseling.
And then working in the school systems are in Montgomery County for many years as a middle school counselor and so on.
So she was able to retire from that one.
She was a school counselor.
My kids went both on the college in Maryland and they enjoyed that.
In fact, my son was still out in there.
And there he was and he said he had to college.
He wanted to be a cop.
He's with the Fairfax County police.
It's just across the river from Washington, D.C.
And he enjoys that a great deal.
My daughter is a nurse that she lives out here in Oregon City,
and works for Kaiser in the Portland area.
Well, I'm going to switch gears a little bit and ask you about books and book collecting.
That's how we first became acquainted with one another.
And I'm interested in knowing what kind of that started.
How did you get into collecting books?
I still have my books from high school.
Nice, a lot of them.
And probably a good portion of my books from Oregon State to some of them.
And so I always just like books and collected books in graduate school.
I always like to read.
And then many of whom we moved to Washington.
And as a Maryland act, I should say, in a D.C. suburb.
I got interested in older books, rare books.
The friend mind was also interested.
And so we sort of got involved in that together back in the 80s.
And got sort of collecting significant volumes back in the late 80s, I think.
And then got interested in the history of printing was fascinating.
And how that affected our culture.
And my mind that the ability to print disseminating information really had a profound effect on our culture.
We don't know our religion.
But education, the change, the change that we live in, they think.
And then allowed everybody, if it can learn to read, to have access to information.
And led to things like the reformation and the root cultural changes.
And then not to speak about how to affect your education.
If you think about it before the print in the book.
Getting in the book was very, very difficult.
Getting knowledge was very, very definitely.
That you had someone had read something.
But to get a copy of a scholarly work prior to the printing press.
You had to be wealthy enough to hire somebody to do it by hand.
So the average person, even the professional person probably wouldn't have any volumes back prior to the printing press.
But the print press was in my mind.
It was a great liberating thing for changing culture.
I just sort of interested in that.
Got interested in the technology of printing.
And then of course, some of the knowledge are just beautiful.
And they want to look at it and how they were.
And how they preserve it.
I always found that fascinating too.
You can buy a book that's 500 years old and open it up.
And it probably looks as, you know, some of them look as good as the day they were.
They were printed.
Like one of the books that the library has is a 50-0-3 Seneca.
It's in Latin.
But it's of Seneca's works.
And that paper is as fresh as the day it was made.
There's no fox in a lot of books in the paper.
A lot of foxes in the paper.
It's just a change in the culture of the paper.
But the last forever seems like.
So it's a fascinating technology.
But just keeping in mind the profound impact that had upon our civilization.
And then how we write it all we are now.
Now, it's comparable change in the last couple decades of how this electronic environment
electronic delivered information is going to affect culture.
It remains to be seen.
How they integrate into this educational process.
And in our general cultural behavior.
So it'll be an interesting thing.
I probably won't live long enough to see the outcome of the orbital.
It's a profound change.
And how people can get information and how you deliver information.
And so things will solve you all.
As they certainly did in the late 15th century when the printing press became available.
And now education never has changed.
So it will be a profound thing.
Tell me a bit about your methods for collecting that scouting out and purchasing in.
I've got a topic of a thing.
If I could get various science things, that's a message.
I always would get that.
If it were something I could afford.
And then it primarily was in history.
I was always at some interest in history.
And in history of printing.
So I have some of the volumes.
I have about purely because they were from a given printer and town,
like being us or whatever, from maybe the 16th century.
But it would be representative of that kind of printing and that that era.
So some of the books of that.
And then there's a wall on scholarly works too.
Like the Seneca.
I mentioned earlier.
And then there's another nice file.
I gave you the Strabo geography, which is a really early production of.
Strabo was a Roman.
Jog first.
Commentaries and maps of the ancient world.
That book is complete with all the diagram maps and diagrams and so forth.
And so it's fascinating to.
If then it's in both Greek and Latin.
And it's fascinating just to look at that and see the.
The the Romans concept of the world was.
I mean the math and the math actually fairly accurate with the.
The curvature.
There's totally displayed and so on and so forth.
So the.
It tells you just shows you just quite graphically how.
How well how much the each is really new about the world.
And they weren't as.
As it's.
As it's sometimes portrayed.
So I I get a kick on then the.
Some of the early scientific stuff.
Do there's a.
Copy of.
It's in French have been frankles work on electricity.
And that was published.
I think with the repubition and this country was published in France when he was.
We spent in time in France.
And so as a.
We'll insight into and to been frankles time as a frankle file.
I mean serving the country in France.
So there's.
And it's a Murray Newton.
It's just.
It's absolutely fascinating.
I think.
There's another interesting very scientific books as well.
Thank you.
They're interesting.
But the scholar things is some good histories.
You know, and this is a good collection of.
Johnson.
The writer poet and that.
Well, and his background for Boswell.
They have a nice set of.
We're really.
And I certainly.
Early.
Productions and publications.
And that's here.
So that's a.
Port part of the cultural history of the.
English speaking people.
Well, it's that things like that would.
With track liners as well as.
There's quite a few travel books of the early travel books.
People would.
Back in the.
This puts things consistent, men and women.
At the same time.
hockey at the same.
Back in the.
Fifteen out of ruins.
Fifteen in the sense in the sense of I
celebrated the one family that
attend to taxes at oh power, they might not see
the second thing you want to see a sense of
thing.
I'm trying to procure those as well because it was an interesting insight into the culture
and history and in that of those tight frames.
Those kinds of things as well, I found interesting and sometimes books are in the beautiful
I mean they're pretty beautiful and the bindings are good shape and you just say, well, I gotta
have that.
Well, I know that you've taken pride in the fact that you actually read these books
to, you know, I'll just put just in it, put them on the shelf.
Exactly.
In fact, I can continue to do so even when I gave where you state the jewelry that you see
this right over here is just collected in the last couple of years which eventually went
up in your library but got a, for example, even in the other room I was saying on the
Stanford office said, I got a really nice Bible that won the first complete English Bible
printed in the United States.
In fact, it's generally thought to be like 1796, the first complete Bible I was some earlier
just new Old Testaments and Ernie Testaments published but this is a complete Bible called
the Collins Bible I believe with the Old Testaments New Testament, all the books of the
Parker for all bound in one and it's a really good shape.
So, that's something I came across just recently in last year or so and there's a, I think
the book of theirs is Poochard's Lies and early Poochard's Lies in English.
So, that's one to sit down and read, Poochard was the Roman bargain for back, back in
so you can want to know about Julius Caesar, Alexander the Great of these people that have
early, early, early printing of a Poochard.
Of course, you can buy and go down and pay the paper back now that the same thing happened.
But here's a nice, early publication of a Poochard.
We spent three decades compiling this collection and made decisions at some point donate it to your
alma mater or every state tell me about the thought process there.
Well, I knew, neither one of my kids is really interested in rare books per se, of course
they'd be interested in the value of their, I mean that goes without saying, right?
I mean, they have to be hindered mentally if they didn't want that, you know, but if you have
a collection like that and people with collections often have this issue, as you get older,
so how do I, you know, what's going to be the ultimate disposal of it, if we, my wife
might both pass, will pass away, if the books were still sitting in the house, the children
wouldn't know how to, you know, they don't particularly want them in their house, but what
would they do with them?
Well, they would call of some estate agent, right?
And then they would sell on somebody being nearby in a $5,000 book for 50 cents, right?
And so that's not too smart.
The other option, well, well, I could start selling them myself.
That is truly a deal of, you could do it, and you might or might not realize very much money,
but the beauty of the donations, you can have them appraised by a good appraiser, and
they stayed together as a collection in the case of, that's what we would have for our
estate.
So others will use them, so it was very satisfying when you were, and somebody tells me
how the students were using, that was the intent.
So we decided that rather than trying to sell them or something, I think we're going to
Oregon State, the benefit to us is, it's a tax deduction.
So we get to realize a tax deduction, so this is a large sum over a period of time, and
help us out financially.
So actually, probably in the end, that's probably more rewarding financially than trying
to sell them, and all that headache.
Plus, the main thing is, they should even get us a collection for others to use, and as
long as I'm able, I can, the current drive down to myself, you see, so we thought it was,
we thought about it a while, and it would be funny to decide that was part of the best
strategy, and then Mr. Meek came up and looked them over, and then he said that the
range was your librarian, faith, to accept the collection, and so it's worked out excellent,
and it's a really satisfying, because the staff of Oregon State is just super in that
library, and then it's been served as students there, because I was student there, and
I don't think there was anything like that there when I was there, and if I was, I was
not cognizant of it, so if we benefit the kids of this state or whoever, we think, that's
very satisfying.
And the main thing is that something we've spent a long time at a massing, and to have
just go to all of the, and try and sell it, it's, it's not, that's rewarding, it is
financially, but that wouldn't mean that much to us. We're comfortable with you tired, and
another few thousand older ones, at this point in our life, it's not going to be particularly
beneficial, so it's much more satisfying to do what we did, and of course, a lot of
Oregon State immediately, and part, because that's where I was graduated and graduated
from, and I liked that the great deal, I have very far members of Oregon State, but also
one of my friends, probably got me thinking about it, so it was Derek Callahan, who was
on your, the alumni, or so she's an foundation for a while, and he didn't raise the
issue about it, but he told me about the kind of things he did, you know, really helping
the University of Race, when he was so forth, and that sort of sparked my mind, well,
me, that's something we could do, you know, to help the University out by, so we can't
go, Derek, put us in contact with something in the foundation, and Ryan is Ryan Robertson
at the time, and working with he, and the light-verse staff put me and so forth, we made
the arrangements, so we have found a good satisfying.
Well, the last thing I want to ask you about is, is your continued connection to OSU,
you're never the library advisory council, OSU is in the midst of a transition expansion
right now, what is your sense of where OSU is at right now, a very different place
from the one that he went to?
It certainly is, and I think what you would pay in, the rest of you have done at the library,
it's just phenomenal.
I mean, the library was not at all like that when I was a student here, and trying to
transition and to take advantage of the modern electronic tools and make it space for the
students to really use.
I'm always impressed when I go down to the places packed.
I was sure, back in the 60s, you find a few people point over the line, but that was
not a lot, so you've turned it into a central learning experience for space for the kids,
you know, I think it's terribly important, I think the transition library to a really
part of the learning environment for the garage number students is, well, it's our
experience, it's fun to be a part of it, so my wife and I are very interested in helping
out anywhere we can, and hopefully we had a lot of experience with books and education
and conveying information, so we think we'd be in some value.
Well, I thank you very much for this, I appreciate quite a lot.
Well, thank you.
It's like good to help out.
Sure.